what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are here to continue
Cobra Kai season 5 episode 8 today John
how are you I am anticipating this very
much and I'm excited and I love you John
is not you you're Andrew Andrew that's
correct uh yes I'm doing well I'm ready
to strike hard show no mercy The Way of
the Fist uh you texted me that you
missed some Easter eggs in a episode I
did I I missed a few here and there but
uh an episode five I was just so happy
and excited I missed she said that I got
10 pounds of mac and cheese for Daniel
that was a reference to Karate Kid Part
three where she had Daniel try her mac
and cheese for dinner and then also too
there was a line by Terry silver where
after he beat the absolute living out of
Daniel he says to him and now the Real
Pain begins Daniel and that was a line
he said to Danny in the 1985 tournament
when he was playing Mike Barnes Greg why
are you looking away from me pay
attention
let's get it out of your system I got it
out we're good all right we'll leave a
like
we will continue this
shaking with the tire code for super
sexually look at our patreon all right
let's get to it
[Music]
Cobra Kai is worthy of Entry
as you can see
our Dojo is state of the art and our
senseis are second to none
look at him flip
they teach that we thank you for your
generosity but this review is entirely
about the quality of your students that
won't be a problem
our Dojo is the best in the valley
that's not true oh damn yeah buddy we've
combined our different styles to train
our students into the best fighters I've
ever seen
and they deserve a shot at your
tournament just as much as Cobra cut
look at that lineup
May the best Dojo win
we will
and when we do I'm going to shove that
ponytail straight up your ass
to translate that they timed that one to
enter there perfectly I know right I
have no rivalry with them
they're beaten this is a last desperate
gasp of breath
I will continue to train your students
so they are fully prepared sit on me
[ __ ] press me
hahaha first you must prove you can
compete with best but in order to do
that you have to be better than the best
which is why we're going to kick your
asses into high gear Sensei Lawrence
Sensei taguchi and I are going to get
you ready for the presentation this is
like cast lineup episode it's the most
expensive episode of the Season hi I'm
bummed actually everything okay with uh
uh yeah
things were tough at first but I'm glad
they were still friends I'm dead inside
I wonder if she found that necklace
a sweet
is this what bodily advice sounds like
Robbie come on just talk relax I'm just
messing with you
the Tui on the same team we actually
have a shot
now what do you say are you ready to
show the world who's boss
oh yeah Bros for life
we use chores to create muscle memory
and once they have that down they can
Master their defense do we teach offense
[Music]
awesome we don't believe in baby steps
we throw our students Straight Into the
Fire Teddy Payne
only started training with us this year
everyone becomes a black belt right away
they only have one doesn't take that
long to get
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
a couple guys on The Cutting Edge
we use the latest technology for maximum
that is so cool it's like Rocky 4 [ __ ]
call That a Kick it's harder
want Santa's all rides on you
I know yeah buddy sometimes you have to
train outside the box to get to another
level
some people use the latest high-tech
junk to get there and some people need
to run up a mountain in the snow and
yell
Rocky Balboa
boys no [ __ ] mine too is
[Laughter]
okay you called Rocky right before it
happened healing power Cinema having
reviewed both dojos it's clear that one
could not be more different than the
other
yeah both are equally impressive
so the only way to determine which Dojo
can gain entry into this oh will come
back each Dojo will select two fighters
one male one female they're male gonna
be Kenny and theirs is gonna be Dimitri
yeah oh it should be no throw Kyler in I
thought the plan was to stop silver and
get you out of here we're not doing
anything like that anymore
the best thing you can do right now is
look after yourself
this is what I get for putting my trust
in anyone
in the end I'm always the one picking up
the pieces
aw Tori having lovers in prison changed
Grace man
maybe we should just flip a coin
how would that work there's three of us
all right so we'll flip three coins
should be Hawk
he beat me fair and square and I about
added last tournament so he deserves to
represent us
wow
it's an honor to take lightly
to be integrals to the season again be a
main character
fight not against opponent
many years ago your father and I had big
fight
do you know a story it's an Easter egg
but I was fighting against
your father was fighting for
fighting for friends for Village ah
chosen you're the best man
for you Sam
for you
your Larusso Prime now Larusso 2.0 fight
4 not against I like that a lot I will
never apply to my actual life but in
terms of the viewing the show she found
the necklace
it's a good thing that that fell right
there
it's been a while you know it's been
several episodes
burning the midnight oil
I don't think I'll be able to sleep
tonight Sensei so I'm gonna exhaust my
body
make sure I'm completely wiped out for
tomorrow
my master taught me this years ago I
call it the Silver Bullet that's good
you like that huh
strike the right speed in trajectory
right between the ribs you can cause
your opponent's significant damage just
break their xiphoid process center right
up into their heart
[Music]
oh my God
look I know how things can start out
from nothing and get bigger and bigger
until all you feel is hate I've been
there I'm telling you
so much better to let that hit go you
and Anthony might actually get along if
you got to know each other you just
gotta hash things out season six thank
you censor silver
matches in your dojo on such a notice
offering or demanding well we do have
actual tournament regulation mats here
so it really was the only option
[Laughter]
damn Eli
underestimating him better kill him kill
Kenny
whoa
[Music]
come on ref that's horseshoe he made
contact inbounds no point
back on the line
Terry silver man
oh you ready d-bag
[Music]
that's a warning turning me a horny you
should be disqualified no it's fine he
just he just caught me off guard are you
sure Eli
no more Eli
it's time to uncage the heart yes my
dude come on
please
oh [ __ ] uh oh
[Music]
give me
can you continue
where's the medic
that's a forfeit
what
[Applause]
can we breathe
I think it's okay just got the wind
knocked out
[Applause]
all right
oh
that Goosebumps everywhere this is awful
looks like you got a new name
faux hawk
that's what he stayed up all my doing
uh uh bird I could probably go to bed
[Laughter]
Samantha Larusso and Tori Nichols please
take the man where is she
oh my god oh nobody saw her leave
what happened to Nichols
Devin's gonna fight oh you know it
you want me to fight Sam Larusso
no
I want you to defeat her
[Music]
[Laughter]
fight
shoulder no point what dude
suspicious he keeps looking right at him
point one zero what did this that's a
block this is so blatant
if I lose the match because of it
you're the better fighter on me everyone
knows it
the ref might not be doing any
one in your corner
all of us
referee is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Point undeniable
I love chosen so much I know we all
deserve a Sensei like him
and a Miguel none of you guys are my
Miguel
oh
no point
what do I do here guys
the dam is broken
oh
my God
point
winner
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she got her ass handed to her yeah buddy
technically 4-0
it's all you yeah
it's a tie break you said to death you
destroyed that not as experienced
fighter Samantha
Your Leader failed you and your
teammates by disappearing
sure Tori had a good reason it does not
matter
if she is not ready to lead
then I must make sure you are
oh my god oh no
Devon's still sweet flowers
she could still be safe turn her into
dark petals
sudden death the skills position and
discipline of the new sekai taikai
qualifier
Cobra Kai
[Applause]
God damn it we admired your unusual mix
of styles and Underdog spirit and we
think you could be a unique addition to
the competition yeah buddy you're a dojo
has also qualified yeah yes
these kids are never gonna go to school
I'm gonna spend our whole lives fighting
for grown man's honor
congratulations gentlemen and welcome to
the second
we just need your dojo's name Miyagi
Feng fangdo
chosen school for wayward children
oh my God Johnny
we represent two opposing philosophies
coming together and finding a common
ground when none seem possible that's
right
if I could change
and you can change
[Applause]
[Laughter]
future got a lot of work to do but
tonight
go celebrate yeah maybe fix that hole in
Hawk's chest
medical attention you guys are on your
own
if you want to host that celebration
look at that bro such good friends now
the baddest badass party
oh no oh close-up means love nice way to
go Miguel the in-between girl
nah it's a hyper performance
she looks so lovely oh no oh no no no no
no no no no no no no
don't do it come on
no no no this is not how it's supposed
to go
foreign
[Music]
you gotta be [ __ ] me
oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
she's she's joining Cobra guy yes
[Music]
oh no no that's so heartbreaking
oh no she's like I know how you feel
oh I don't care about Miguel anymore
what
wow golly
God damn it Miguel
oh
good for him yeah man look like it
happened so fast
he's the one who hooked him up what was
the passage of time between this is the
[ __ ] too they're making out like she got
drunk very fast very impressive very
impressive was the message there you
have to get a woman drunk to hook up
with her no the message is star and Blue
Beetle
all right Andrew take it away Andrew you
gotta align your heads with us or else
we all go out of focus
so you're like leaning forward is that
better no no no not straight up it's
it's
the what's the not perpendicular uh
parallel parallel with us am I good now
as you see uh you look a little ahead of
us yeah all right
maybe relax a little bit better
let me scooch back a little bit if your
natural things lean forward you know no
no I'm like switch the chair back and
then you can lean forward yeah all right
thank you Greg anyways we're way out of
focus the whole video because we're just
focusing on my Android it's gonna be two
blurry faces
anyways uh for Easter eggs and
references uh so we got uh Kenny doing
the elbow move on Eli's leg that was
very reminiscent in mirroring of what
Johnny did to Daniel right before the
crane kick in the first Karate Kid film
at the all Valley tournament we got
obviously we had the rocky reference so
more didn't need to be said about that
one we also got uh the whole story about
that Johnny was about to tell with Mr
Miyagi and the other sensei's of Miyagi
dough that was what Mr Miyagi told
Daniel in Karate Kid Part two and then
we also got
um I know there's another reference that
there was I know I'm feeling you Greg I
will think of it in a little bit right
say uh the the sand the floor when uh
chosen was showing them sand the floor
Mr Miyagi asked Daniel to show them sand
uh show Daniel sand the floor uh after
he'd done all the muscle memory uh
drills so there's that one yes dude yep
there you go in regards to this episode
uh definitely I mean I still liked
episode seven but from the emotional
payoff that we got from episode six it
was I wouldn't say a step down but
definitely a change of range of episode
um not the same level I would say but uh
this got right back up there for me in
terms of uh how impressive again just
how good the quality how good this
episode was I loved it I love the the
little exhibition tournament we got and
again just seeing Rocky IV exactly uh I
love Apollo and Drago had to fight each
other oh is that what happened that's an
exhibition when are we gonna get the
robot in this series uh anyways but I
thought this episode was great uh again
seeing thomasine Griffith's performing
okay just stands out for me just he
always elevates every episode with his
level of quality of his performance and
I just love his influence on I mean I
don't like from a character perspective
what he's doing to Kenny but just from
character interactions and his acting I
just I love uh his interactions with
Kenny and what he's doing them and also
love too the ark that Robbie has gone
through where he's taken a step back and
now he's seen like what's happening and
and the way like Kenny reacted to him
training Anthony it's like just that
that fuse that went off it's like it's
it's really impressive to see how
different Kenny has what we saw the
nerdy kid that was dancing in front of
the bus that got embarrassed to the the
really mean bullying kid that we see now
before us and he was kind of turned into
that obviously brainwashed of course by
silver and Cobra Kai but also from The
Bullying he received from Anthony and
his friends but it's it's an amazing
transformation we need to get him as
Miles Morales one day in the MCU by the
way that actor is really good uh but
this episode is great and I I also I
freaking love the actor who plays chosen
he is so damn good I just that the
inspiration he instills into his
students especially that that what he
said to Sam you know don't fight for or
fight for not against I just that was so
beautiful it gives you a different
perspective too when you think about
Karate Kid Part Two in that final fight
as well so you know whenever I rewatch
that which these guys know I rewatch
that series often uh it's gonna give me
a yeah right it's going to give me a
different level of perspective when I
re-watch that fight and that's what I
love about this show is whenever New
Seasons come out it gives me a different
level of perspective whenever I re-watch
the series especially season three you
know when we got to see the crease and
Terry Silver's backstory like it gave me
a different level of perspective like
just the history of those two characters
and their backstory and their history
and it just adds so many more layers and
that's what I love and what these the
creators of the show they're just so
respectful to the previous series of The
Karate Kid but while ingratiating new
and interest testing story ideas and
beats and character interactions and
that's why I love this show so much
they still have done nothing to fix The
Next Karate Kid dude it's gonna happen
we're gonna get Hillary swing John and I
were talking about that off camera it's
happening this show is too popular it's
gonna happen you're gonna fix that movie
guys she'll be one of the surprise
judges of the sekai taikai
um
John what would you think oh uh it was
uh it was it was the show
um no it was great I love this episode I
I thought that yeah I kind of agree the
last episode was maybe the the least
sort of emotionally punch-heavy episode
eloquent as that sounded just now um but
yeah I thought this one brought it
nicely back
I thought those were 3D glasses for a
second there yeah James Cameron gave
them to me good yeah we're buddies uh
but no Jim this this brought it right
back to the to the combination of yeah I
mean we have the arrival of the judges
and there's a lot going on and we're
seeing both teams perspectives but it's
like it had that emotional resonance to
go along with the intensity of the
circumstances to yeah feel like I've
said uh in one of the earlier reviews
it's like each episode this season as
much as Cobra Kai is like a
quintessentially binge-worthy show I
felt each one could stand on its own and
and yeah the previous one maybe not so
much but this one kind of returned to
that where I was just so engrossed yeah
in watching everybody's sort of
struggles and the growth that's on
display especially with a character like
Robbie uh you know kind of being the Zen
master now as hawk steps up to him and
he's like no no like you can see the old
Hawk still kind of lingering as he's
like I'll shut him up for you and you
can see just how much Robbie has
progressed in a moment like that when
he's like no it's Cobra Kai talking like
it's it's the indoctrinations the
brainwashing you know and we have to be
above that we have to be able to see
that and two you know with Sam and uh
Daniel even their sort of relationship
everybody kind of encouraging each other
to just go and do what is right uh or
what you you know feel is best for you
and uh yeah I thought this episode had
great humor across the board I really
liked like you can kind of
it got me wondering a little bit but I
figured it would come down to some kind
of uh you know sequence of events where
they'll both make it into the tournament
but I still thought they rung some good
tension out of that and by the end like
the fights I think thought got really
intense and the emotional stuff got
intense because like I was like tearing
up at the very very end of the episode
with that Sam stuff and then the Wallop
of Tori being like hey now is time for
the dams of Truth to break and I'm gonna
come clean about all this stuff uh yeah
I could go on and you just reminded me
when Miguel said I'm in your I'm in your
corner Sam at that exhibition that's he
said that to Sam at the end of uh season
four episode ten so did you guys
recognize also that actor uh who is the
head of that committee the one who was
trying to place it I know I've seen that
D2 the Mighty Ducks
the first Alien versus Predator oh wowie
okay yeah no I could go on and on about
this episode but we should hear what you
think yes Greg she trained what did you
think Greg what do you think G you guys
left nothing for me to talk about
all right all right guys let's move on
to better things now
so between Johnny
Chosen and Daniel oh no which one are we
oh uh you're chosen for sure I'm chosen
no I feel like he's chosen
jeez all right he's the wise one here
Johnny what makes me chosen so not
chosen because you're badass that's John
you're like Johnny you're like real
badass Johnny I'm the sarcastic [ __ ]
you're you're Johnny Andrew's Chosen and
I guess I'm Danny
oh my God don't go racist
I'm imitating God whenever I imitate
guys form a flattery is imitation but
Greg would call it racism I I know for
sure it's racism just when we were in
filming you're like yo what's up I'm
up I was like Andrew you can't do that
man and then you're like hey Miguel is
safe like he doesn't even make it I'm
gonna beat on me
I was like Andrew please people might
hear you oh Sam I'm a girl yeah and you
were kind of doubling down your chosen
impression with the cameras are rolling
oh
[Laughter]
look at it dude that is so racist you
better you better cut it out yeah
I feel bad for Miguel Scissorhands in
the next episode because Sam is gonna
beat him up
um yeah octopus style uh I I love Sam I
really I really root for her I mean I
think um you know what did you expect
though man kept him he keep keep
breaking up with him and not being with
him
bound to hook up with someone in between
technically single you didn't know about
he didn't know you got the necklace we
were on a break they were they were on a
break they detected he technically
didn't do anything wrong no technically
true
It's just sad it sucks I get it though
on the empathetic side for Sam I totally
get that yeah walk into that you have a
goal and you're like I'm gonna doll
myself up and saw the necklace and uh
yeah I'm ready to give this another go
I'm finding myself again I'm coming
becoming grounded with myself again I
won this fight uh yeah I'm gonna go back
I'm ready to continue and then bam you
see him making out with someone yeah
that that sucks
and I loved his reaction he was like
whereas Andrew would say I don't know me
hey you don't know what you're talking
about I don't know what happened now I
would say if I were to nitpick one one
thing in this episode was it was a
little generic formulaic in terms of the
timing of certain things like she
dropped her water ball there was the
necklace she came in right as he was
making out with someone and certain
things like that but that's I mean
that's typical in movies and TV shows
typical yeah very very typical look over
a guy especially yeah and then also when
they walked into the uh at the very
beginning of the episode when they were
talking to the committee they walked in
right around the corner going wait wait
oh wait the committee's in let's go in
now this is the time it's very Cobra Kai
though it's part of the cheesy Punch
Yeah you got freaking this villainous
Japanese woman
so ridiculous it's just like but it's
awesome
Korean oh is it Korean I thought they
were Japanese I would so say karate I'm
not sure Japanese I feel like there was
a detail they might be racist
oh what is South Korea you're right
South Korea Masters
I'm good I've I've been racist enough on
this video I was the only one caught it
called out for his racism I thought she
was Japanese because I won karate
Japanese don't mess it up
uh yeah I think she's so great and uh I
really like Devin a lot too yeah I don't
want her to change too much
because I want her to be good and uh
Cree seems like he's
you know
he's probably he probably has a couple
of lovers in prison now yeah we should
calm down yeah he's gonna go be on a
commune with his seven lovers yeah yeah
it's good stuff good stuff uh so yeah
I'm really I really I think Mary Master
doesn't get enough credit she's one of
the most popular actors in the show but
I just want to show my support for Mary
Master she's uh excellent through that
and Hawk getting a moment to shine as
well a Kenny guy he's obnoxious man he's
rakai sometimes sometimes she's like you
guys are so obnoxious how do you guys
even have be friends with each other it
seems like your whole outlook is just
being a dick all the time awful people
they're just awful people
but yeah you guys said all the best
points and uh this was intense and I
don't know I like I like when the show
just pushes those limits at the end
where I'm like no you're gonna do the
thing I don't want you to do yeah yeah
but whatever man he got over you like
banging Robbie
it's true she slept with Robbie didn't
she
I don't believe they slept together and
that's not not remembering but when
you're teenagers it's like the
equivalent of sleeping again you did it
okay like a kiss is like the equivalent
okay yes they slept together multiple
times then yes I think Andrew's mad
because we called him out for his racism
it's okay
this is what happens check your white
privilege and your address officially
reached the John Point yes
like you've made fun of me too much
disguised as a joke or not I can't no I
can't laugh along anymore with the jokes
I'm sorry Andrew I'm sorry it's okay
that's What Makes You chosen
[Laughter]
thanks man yeah right I'm gonna get you
guys both a bonsai you're Danny yeah the
sweet nice guy with uh anger just right
on the version there's always been a
little Cobra kind of so it's a little
bit of a of a temper just waiting to
burst out yeah yeah and wait till I get
to my Karate Kid three phase wait till I
find my Terry silver all right guys
let's watch the next episode thanks for
being here subscribe click that Bell
Andrew you want to close this out with a
patron of the days just say Patron the
day shut up patron of the day shout out
you didn't do it in your chosen voice
picture of the day shout out very good
goody you held back
nice
Chase Gardner we've looked up your name
on Urban Dictionary and here's what it
means
Chase is the most kind sweet caring
handsome smart lovable wonderful guy you
will ever meet every adjective in there
oh my God you're just like The Best of
the Best of the Best of the Best of the
Best Pandora's best he is the best
boyfriend and greatest friend what wow
Chase I think you're trying too hard to
sell yourself both kinds of friends he
does seem to get very jealous easily did
you get in a fight with your girlfriend
Chase is that what's going on here Chase
goes through a lot but never emits it
until you have his full trust sounds
like you need to better open
communication skills Chase Jesus talk
just talk to me he often feels insecure
and no matter how many times you tell
him how wonderful he is he still has a
hard time believing it
so much that he wrote this entry here
chase you just really need to go to
therapy and perhaps go to couples
counseling if that helps you better talk
with your loved one especially instead
of just being like I have a hard time
opening up he can be shy but he still
has somewhat courage and confidence uh
yeah also you land all these ladies who
you're totally driving up the Wazoo the
lion in sheep's clothing my friend he
doesn't like to get into fights but if
he has to he will protect you no matter
what dude that is true thank you Chase
Chase is a warrior we call him Warrior
Chase around these parts of the patreon
page we are the chase tribe we follow
him anywhere he wants to go chase
once you realize that
you don't need to run after anything
anymore
that life is chasing after you accept it
you've already been chased
it's present be embraced chaste
you know all right thanks Chase
[Music]